the complexity of giving people money is
vastly underestimated
agreed because it raises a lot of
questions that we should have been
asking for a long time and everything
else
so what happens when you say well you're
just gonna give a lot of people money
they say well how do you know it's the
right people great question
that's called targeting in the
literature but it applies to everything
if i was giving people sheep how do you
know it's the right people
you would definitely need to make sure
you were giving a sheep to the right
person if you gave
the wrong person a sheep
the biggest would go poorly for both the
sheep and uh
you know maybe the person yeah we uh i
didn't bring a sheep for you today i'm
sorry andrew
that's totally fine i would have been
one of the wrong people
so you've got the targeting problem
right so that's problem one
second problem people say well how do
you know there's not fraud
if you're giving people money surely
people are going to try to steal it
and the answer is they do and you have
to build systems for that
but you know what that's true of every
development program and every social
program
and one of my favorite answers to that
is yeah but cash is really valuable
wait a second so we're going to say
we're going to give people things that
are not valuable
lest other people try to defraud the
system that logic doesn't make sense
so how do you deal with fraud how do you
make sure you're not
causing issues in the community of any
sort right you don't want to be
invoking domestic violence as it turns
out cash reduces domestic violence yes
you want to make sure that you're not
altering power you have to be very
thoughtful about that
and then you have to be very aware of
both local and national political
structures like
people get worried are you giving to one
ethnic group over another
are you trying to affect the next
election and those are the things
i was trying to really thought
[Laughter]
we do not try to affect the next
elections um
that's the difference between you and me
by growing up so so uh well cash is very
popular
uh from a government standpoint even a
majority i mean a majority of people are
for it
uh uh here in america and now happily uh
when i got started
the the uh approval rate for universal
basic income was
i think something like 24 it was not
high
and now it's last i checked it was like
56
percent um so i think it's incredible
what's happening over the last two years
and
you obviously played a central role in
that but i think perception
well you played a central role in
helping me know that
it's real and actionable um so uh so row
he shows up in kenya
uh in the mid 2000s and starts gathering
phone numbers
and then he comes back and he's like
okay guys i got some phone numbers like
you know
like so so then you uh raised some money
and started sending it to people like
well
i i i repeated the endeavor uh shortly
thereafter so you went too and you were
like we need more phone numbers it's my
turn
yeah and i'm very distinctly walking
around the camp asking people for their
number
a lot of people saying no are you part
of the illuminati no one's ever given me
something for free what are you going to
ask me for i just don't trust you
you spend a lot of time and we did that
one of my
favorite um memories of that trip was
there's a little store
outside the uh outside the area and it
was empty
it was completely abandoned and you can
imagine going in and saying well what
are we going to give people cash for
there's nothing to buy here there's no
market there's no stores
you gave people money guess what the
store started to fill up
because it made sense for the shopkeeper
to go back to buy inventory and start
selling things
and that you see in the research since
which is you actually
not only have an impact on the people
that get cash
but on those that don't get cash and the
broader economy
yeah and there's a very important point
there which is that
uh that the the market will
seek out people that have the resources
uh if you're not able to participate in
the market then you go to the town
you're like well there's nothing going
on here but
if all of a sudden the people in that
town had money then
uh there would be a like a business
that's serving them um or they'd started
themselves because they look up and say
wait a minute you know it's like
we we need uh we need to shop here and
like i can do that and then it starts as
like a basic food stand and everything
else
markets respond and they respond quickly
and surely there are places where that
may not be the case because you're so
far off the grid
i mean it's working it's kind of working
i mean
we're doing this in liberia yeah you can
do it in very tough places and
liberia doesn't even print their own
money they have to get it
brought in on boats um there was really
no mobile money infrastructure in
liberia when we got started
there's a rainy season which cuts off
large parts of the country
so what happened now how many countries
have you been in 11 countries 11
countries that's so fun
um so so you and and the band of grad
students then started sending small sums
uh to two people what was like the total
number of people you were sending money
to in that first
uh gosh i must have spent a whopping
five thousand dollars so still forget
how much money we uh
i mean it's still legit especially uh
after it translates to
um kenya i mean like you know it'd be
enormously impactful i'm sure when
people
first started getting money they were
freaking out oh yeah
um that's what we did then we tried to
experiment with the operations
right say okay can i just hire the
village elder and ask him
to pick the people and give it out well
that probably didn't work so well
that would have problems he picks his
friends and family yeah that one that
one was obvious in retrospect
can we pay in peso agents because
they're already going around on
motorbikes delivering sim cards and
things can they be part of this
well that worked okay and how do you
start to put the checks and balances in
place
to build out this robust cash
distribution infrastructure
and that's what we did and we've evolved
a lot a decade later
well so then uh then who who's the first
um investor supporter that recognizes
that what you're doing is profound and
says you know what
instead of you just doing big sales and
like getting a few hundred bucks from
your friends we're gonna give like you
know
you this like who is the the first to
figure it out
yeah so it was a friend named vivek who
i have to give credit for he uh
he had his first finance job and said
this is great
like i want to fund some of this and
gave us a bit more
uh money and said see if we can grow
this
we then launched a research project
because we were academics and
before scaling anything we wanted to
know that exactly what we were doing
also worked yes we had evidence on cash
but we did not yet have evidence on us
and we wanted to build that so we did
our first research project use some
research funds for
two two too much research man should
have yeah been like we know this works
like god's blazing yeah i i i hear you
with the money
i'm just kidding well it helped it
helped and it helped because there are a
lot of people that wanted to engage
and that's what was nice so the first
big check that we got
um well there are two one was unorthodox
philanthropy and
uh the lampard family uh which is an
incredible story
yes they he said you know we had a big
stack of applications
it's one of these programs where you
submit a page or two wow
that works it was it was a few thousand
dollars at the time
oh wow and he'll tell the story he
remembers someone pulling out the stack
and saying
this is the worst application i've ever
seen this goes against
everything we do in the sector and we
cannot fund this
mark being mark said what is that one
that one was give directly
so that was the next step and then once
we had run the research we had gone over
to see google.org
and they said at some level we don't
care what you're doing let's
show me the data let's engage at the
data level
and to their credit they engage in the
data and they said this is really good
and then challenged us to think bigger i
remember going in i forget what we were
asking maybe it was hundred thousand two
hundred thousand dollars at two hundred
thousand dollars
what if we gave you a few million
dollars could you open a new country
could you expand this
because this could be a billion dollars
two billion dollars to the poor
[Music]
foreign